what I have to say is a pretty good
representation of what the foreign policy
elite in Russia is thinking.
The West is leading
Ukraine down the primrose
path, and the Israelis
are executing a genocide in Gaza.
It's not China's fault
that it wants to be powerful.
So if you get into trouble and you
dial 911, there's nobody at the other end.
Hi this is John Mearsheimer.
I would like to speak today
in this episode about my recent trip
to Russia, which took place
between September 8th and September 12th.
Those were the days that
I was in the country not traveling there.
I started off in Moscow
and I spent a few days in Moscow,
and then the second half of my trip
was in Saint Petersburg.
And what exactly did I do there?
I gave a series of talks.
I participated in some roundtable
discussions.
I interviewed a number of people
who I have known over the years.
I had dinner one
evening with the Foreign Minister,
Sergey Lavrov, which lasted for
well over two hours at his residence.
And I spent a lot of time
wandering around during the daytime
and in the evening in both Moscow and
Saint Petersburg, because I like to walk.
And I wanted to see both of those cities,
or at least as much of those cities
as I could see by walking around.
Who exactly did I talk to?
I talked to a large number of people
who I would describe as being members
of the foreign policy elite inside of Russia.
I talked to a number of people who I know,
going back to the days of the Cold War,
when they were Soviet citizens,
not Russian citizens.
As I said, I talked to Foreign Minister
Lavrov and I talked to his deputy,
who I have talked to in the past
when I went to Russia.
And I think I got a pretty good feel
from talking to everyone
that I just mentioned of sort
of how the Russian elite in general
is thinking about the present situation
regarding the Ukraine war.
But nevertheless, having said
all that, you should understand
that what I have to say
is largely anecdotal.
I didn't go in and do a survey
of what elite
opinion is on a particular issue,
and I certainly didn't talk to
large numbers of people in the street.
So this is anecdotal,
but I think what I have to say
is a pretty good representation
of what the foreign policy elite in
Russia is thinking.
Let me start by talking about what I saw
regarding daily life
inside of Moscow and Saint Petersburg.
I would say it was remarkably normal
that there were few signs of a war
taking place.
Walking around in those two cities
is not much different
than walking around in places
like New York or places like Chicago.
There were a few signs of the war.
However, I think the most obvious sign
was that at a number of what
they call petrol stations or what
we call gas stations, you saw long lines.
In some cases, the lines
included maybe 15 or 20 cars.
In one case, I think the line
probably included about 40 to 50 cars.
That was not true
at every petrol station or gas station,
but it was true at a number of them.
And this is consistent
with what we read in the newspapers,
some other signs of the war
that I would note.
First of all, the sanctions have had
a significant effect in the sense
that if you go into Russia,
you cannot use your own credit card
or an American credit card,
and you can't use American money.
I did not go in to Russia realizing that.
So I was in fact, effectively penniless
when I was in Russia.
If I went to a store or went to a coffee
shop, I had to make sure
I went with somebody who could pay for me
because I had no ability to pay.
I couldn't use any of my credit cards.
I couldn't use American dollars.
You could only use Russian credit cards
or rubles.
And I didn't have any of them.
Correspondingly,
the Russians cannot
use American credit cards.
So if you're a Russian
and you want to subscribe
to the New York Times,
you can't use an American credit card
to subscribe because American credit cards
can't be used in Russia.
So you would have to use
your Russian credit card.
But the problem is you can't use
a Russian credit card in the West.
So any Russian who wants to subscribe to
the New York Times or the Wall Street
Journal or some Substack site
cannot do it through normal channels.
So you see the effect of sanctions there.
One other
sign of the effect of sanctions was
that there were a number of coffee shops
that you could tell that were once
Starbucks coffee shops
that are now star coffee shops,
but have an emblem that resembles
or a symbol that resembles
the old Starbucks
symbol that was once there.
But nevertheless, despite
the long lines that I saw
at a few gas stations,
and despite the problem with credit cards
and using dollars,
there were hardly any signs
that normal life
was not going on inside of both Moscow
and Saint Petersburg.
If you went into restaurants,
you looked around
in department stores or drugstores,
and he walked around on the streets.
Everything looked remarkably normal.
Just one final point on this.
Before the war started on February 22nd.
Excuse me. February 24th of 2022.
It was possible to fly from the
United States or from Europe into Russia.
That's no longer the case.
So I had to fly from Chicago to Istanbul
and then from Istanbul into Russia.
Because you cannot fly directly
from any place in the west,
inside to inside Russia.
Let me talk a little bit
about the economy.
As I'm sure almost everybody knows,
when the war started.
Our goal
was to bring the Russian economy.
To to bring the Russian economy
to its knees, to do egregious damage
to the Russian economy.
It was widely believed
that that would help
us, in effect, win the war against Russia.
You saw no signs
that the Russian economy is in trouble.
This is not to argue that
everything is hunky dory
with the Russian economy,
but it did not seem to me
that there was any evidence
that the Russian economy was struggling.
And there was nobody that I
talked to
who talked about economic problems
or dangers ahead
regarding the Russian economy.
There may be lurking problems there
that people are concerned about,
and they just didn't tell me.
But all I would say is that the whole time
I was there,
I saw no signs
that the Russian economy is in trouble.
In fact, it looked like
the Russian economy is doing quite well.
And again, nobody in in the time I was
there
said that the Russians were concerned
about where
their economy was headed.
Now, I would note that the situation in
Russia is fundamentally different
than the situation in Ukraine.
There were just many times when I was
observing what was going on in Russia.
I thought to myself, how does this compare
to what's going on in Ukraine?
And it's quite clear that the Ukrainians
are in a very different situation.
And in fact,
one of the days that I was in Russia,
a headline appeared in the New York Times
that said that the Russians desperate.
Excuse me.
The Ukrainians desperately needed $27
billion
more in economic and military aid.
They were, in effect,
running out of money.
And what this points up
is that the Ukrainian economy
is basically been wrecked and Ukraine is.
In need of great
support from the West to survive.
The Ukrainians could not fight the war
without massive amounts
of economic assistance from the West.
Situation is fundamentally different
in Russia.
Russia is not depending
on assistance from anyone.
And as I said, I do not believe the
Russian economy is in desperate straits.
There is no evidence of that.
It seems to be humming along
relatively well.
And again, that situation contrasts
with the situation in Ukraine.
And furthermore, I had no sense
that there were food shortages
or that people were suffering in
any meaningful way
inside of Russia, whereas
there's no question that that is the case
inside of Ukraine,
especially in recent months
with the shutdown of the Black Sea
ports in Ukraine.
So there's a fundamental difference here
between the two.
One final point on
that has to do with weaponry.
It's quite clear that not only is
the Russian economy in quite good shape,
but the Russians are producing
massive amounts of weaponry.
People talked about that quite often.
The number of weapons that are coming off
the assembly lines is quite impressive.
And again,
the exact opposite is the case in Ukraine.
Ukraine is desperate for weapons
from the West.
You hear the Ukrainians constantly
talking about
the need for Patriot missiles,
the so-called Pac three missiles,
to help them deal with the Russian
onslaught of missiles and drones.
But the West is in no position
to give Ukraine.
The weaponry it needs to deal with
those aerial attacks from Russia.
But on the Russian side, again,
there's no shortage
of weaponry, both defensive missiles
and offensive missiles.
So, the contrast between
Russia and Ukraine is quite stark.
And I think the Ukrainians
are in real trouble.
And as I say, when you talk
about the economy, I think in the
Russian case,
things are in pretty good shape.
Now, let's talk a little bit
about a little bit
about the political situation
inside of Russia.
It has long been argued in the West
that Putin is in political trouble
and that he may be toppled.
And of course, the belief in the West
is that if Putin is toppled,
he will be replaced
by a more reasonable person.
And by that, most people in the West
believe that his replacement would be
someone who was willing to negotiate
an end to the war with the West.
That person would be more dovish
or softer than Putin,
who was widely seen in
the West as highly aggressive.
Now, I pushed people very hard
on this particular issue
and people would talk about it.
But I do want to emphasize that I think
there are limits to what people would say.
I think most people are reluctant
to be too critical
of Putin for obvious reasons.
So, I'm, I'm aware that
people were not completely frank
on this particular issue.
Nevertheless, I saw no evidence of
the belief that Putin was in trouble
politically
and that he was likely to be toppled
because of dissatisfaction
with his leadership.
Now, it may be the case that behind
the scenes, forces are at play
that are going to bring
Putin down at some point
in time for one reason or another.
But all I would say is I did not see
a hint of that argument.
Now, there's no question
that there has been dissatisfaction
for Putin for a few years now.
You want to remember the war has been
going on for more than four years.
We're now into the fifth year of the war.
And I would say over the past two,
maybe three years,
there has been dissatisfaction with Putin.
But the dissatisfaction has to do
with the fact that many people believe,
and they will say this to you,
that he has not been waging the war
vigorously enough,
that he is not been tough enough
in attacking Ukraine,
both on the battlefield
and with the air war.
Now, it's important to emphasize
that that situation
has been rectified since about June.
The Russians have greatly ramped up
their attacks on Ukraine,
and it is unequivocally clear
that they're going to increase
the intensity
of the attacks on Ukraine moving forward.
So that dissatisfaction with Putin,
it once existed because many people felt
he was not waging the war was sufficient,
with sufficient vigor has gone away.
So the dissatisfaction
is, in effect, gone away.
Now, all of this tells you that
if Putin were to be replaced,
let's assume that Putin
had a heart attack and could not continue
being the Russian president, and somebody
came into office to replace him.
That person would be
at least as hawkish as him,
if not more hawkish,
even if Putin had been replaced
a year or two ago,
the person who replaced him
would not have been more interested
in accommodating the West.
There's no evidence
that the widespread belief in the West
that Putin's replacement would have been
something of a pussy cat was correct.
If anything, Putin's replacement
would have been a hard liner.
But the point I'm making to you
now is that Putin has become a hardliner
when it comes to the whole question
of how to wage this war.
And the Russians are waging the war
very vigorously.
One other point about the politics
that's worth making.
It's very clear
from talking to Russians and,
listening to what they have to say
about their country and what's going on.
They're very nationalistic
that all sorts of people
will talk about Russian civilization
in a proud way.
They will distinguish Russia
from the West.
And it's very clear
that a good number of Russians
that I talk to do not like the West,
because they do not like liberal values
and the values that they privilege.
Focus more on things like civilization,
excuse me, like religion,
Christianity in particular,
the family one would call
traditional values
a lot of emphasis on traditional values
among people that I spoke to.
And those people sometimes distinguish
the traditional values
that they privilege in Russia
from liberal values in the West.
In a funny way,
when I talk to a number of Russians
about this subject of Russian nationalism,
they sounded a lot like JD Vance.
So that's what I would say
about the political situation
inside of Russia
based on my conversations.
Now, let me say some words on
what I think
the course of the war looks like.
I think, as I said, the Russians
this past summer decided to escalate
in a massive way.
As I've talked about in
previous episodes,
the Russians have basically
turned Ukraine into a landlocked country,
and they have shut down
all the Ukrainian Black Sea ports,
which is causing massive economic problems
inside of Ukraine.
The Russians have also made it clear
that they're going to try
to totally destroy the energy
infrastructure inside of Ukraine.
And what's important to understand here
is that for political reasons,
the Russians have no choice
but to escalate.
Putin clearly understands,
and the Russian elite clearly understands,
that it's politically unacceptable
to let this war just go on and on,
and that it's politically unacceptable
to let the Ukrainians
attack targets
inside of Russia with their drones.
And there's no question
that that is happening.
Although I saw virtually no evidence
of those Ukrainian drone attacks
when I was in either Saint Petersburg
or in Moscow, save for the long
gasoline for the long lines
at the gasoline station.
But other than that,
there was no evidence of
the air campaign
that Ukraine is waging against Russia.
Nevertheless, it's quite clear
the Russians consider this
to be intolerable,
and they are bent on ending it.
They are bent on ending the war.
And the way they're going to do
that is to escalate.
So the politics of the conflict
leave the Russians
no choice but to escalate and escalate.
They will.
Now, when you talk about what
this all leads to,
the Russians will make it clear
that they intend to win the war,
and they're actually quite confident
about that.
I was a bit taken aback
by how sure of themselves
the Russian elites were that
they were going to win the war.
And I think that's due in part, again,
based on my conversations,
to the fact that the Russians believe
the Ukrainians are in deep trouble.
And that Russia can ramp up
the pressure on Ukraine
and basically bring this war to an end.
Now, let me talk a little bit
about what escalation means here.
I think the Russians see themselves
as putting great pressure on Ukraine,
up on the front lines,
on what we like to call the battlefield.
And there's a clear understanding that
there are significant cracks
in the front line
forces on the Ukrainian side,
and that the Russians
are making significant progress.
But the progress is slow.
And everybody will tell you,
unsurprisingly,
that that's because of the drones.
There's no question that the drones
have changed the nature of.
Of of what's happening
on the battlefield in quite profound ways.
A number of Ukrainians said to me
that if there were no drones,
this war would have ended two
maybe three years ago.
I think that's correct.
I think it would have ended more like 1
or 2 years ago if there were no drones.
Drones have allowed the Ukrainians
to hold off the Russians
on the battlefield.
So when the Russians talk now
about escalating and finishing
off the Ukrainians, the emphasis
is not so much on the battlefield itself.
The battlefield defined in rather narrow
term,
in rather narrow terms, talking about
what's happening up on the front lines.
I think the Russians believe
that they will deliver the coup de grace
by basically wrecking Ukraine.
In terms of its economic and military
infrastructure behind the front lines,
I think that the Russians believe that
cutting off Ukraine from its Black Sea
ports, destroying its energy
infrastructure, destroying all sorts
of military infrastructure in rear areas
to include things like bridges,
railroad lines, locomotives, gas stations
and so forth
and so on will do so much damage
to the Ukrainian economy
and to the support system
behind the Ukraine front line forces,
that those front line
forces will just collapse
and Russia will win the war.
So what I'm trying to say here is that
what's happening up on the battlefield,
narrowly defined,
does matter for sure to the Russians.
But I think at this point in time,
the Russians tend to believe
that the strategic bombing
campaign is their real ace in the hole.
And now that they have decided
since the summer of this year
to really ramp up that campaign,
they think they can bring the Ukrainians
to their knees.
And just one final point
about this, to tie
it back to the discussion of the economy.
The fact that the Russians
have this ability to produce vast amounts
of weaponry, vast around amounts
of missiles and drones and aircraft
and so forth
and so on, is what I think gives them
confidence that they can wreck
the Ukrainian economy and they can wreck
that military support system
behind the front lines as well.
My final
point here, and I said this before,
but I think it's important to emphasize,
is that almost everybody I talked to
was very confident
that Russia is going to win this war.
Let me switch gears now and talk
about how the Russians
think about their adversaries.
I think with regard
to the Ukrainians,
I did not have the sense
that there was any deep hatred inside
of Russia towards the Ukrainians.
And the reason is that
many Russians who I talked to emphasize
that they had relatives
who lived in Ukraine.
There are huge numbers of Russians
who have both.
One might call a Ukrainian heritage
and a Russian heritage.
And lots of Russians
that I talked to viewed
Ukrainians as blood
brothers and blood sisters.
This is not to say that
they don't understand that there's a war
taking place between Ukraine and Russia,
and there's obviously
a huge amount of animosity
that comes with that on the Russian side.
But I do think that on the Russian side,
anyway, that animosity was somewhat
qualified by the fact that Russians
and Ukrainians, ethnic Russians and ethnic
Ukrainians have been intermingled
or have intermingled over time.
And therefore,
there are lots of people who have both
Russian and Ukrainian heritage.
And that, I think, ameliorate
the level of animosity.
And by the way, many people, I'm sure,
remember the famous article
that Vladimir Putin
wrote on July 12th, 2021.
This is about six months
before the war broke out.
Putin wrote this famous article
where he emphasized
that Ukrainians and Russians
were part of one large family.
And he did not see a clear distinction
between Russians on one hand
and Ukrainians on the other hand.
What I'm saying here
is that in my conversations
with Russia, Russians
during my recent trip,
there were lots of people who basically
were making the same argument
that Putin made in that famous
July 12th, 2021.
Article that he wrote.
So I would just say that when it comes
to Russian views of the Ukrainian people
and the country of Ukraine,
the animosity is somewhat qualified.
And I don't want to overstate
the case here, because I understand that
a war is taking place.
Now, putting the Ukrainians aside
and focusing on the Europeans.
The Europeans are the ultimate bad guys
for the Russians.
You see that very clearly with everyone
you talk to.
And this is certainly true in the dinner
that I had with Foreign Minister Lavrov.
The Europeans are seen as being bent
on destroying
Russia, knocking Russia
out of the ranks of the great powers.
And I think the Russians believe
that the Europeans
want to use Ukraine to achieve that goal.
The Russians believe that the Europeans
themselves don't want to do the fighting,
but they want the Ukrainians
to do the fighting and dying,
all for the purposes of wrecking Russia
as a great power.
To take this a step further.
It's very clear that the Russians view
the British and the Germans
as the ultimate bad guys.
They believed that Britain has long been
the driving force behind European policy.
And now the Germans
under Chancellor Merz
have become a huge problem.
You want to remember that
the Second World
War is emblazoned in the brains
of almost everyone
in the Russian elite,
and the Second World War involves
the events on the Eastern Front
between June 22nd, 1941 and May 8th, 1945.
And the Russians are well aware
of the enormous damage,
the death and destruction
that the Germans inflicted on Russia.
So Germany is a very special threat
to Russia because of what's happened,
because of what happened in World War two.
So when Chancellor Merz begins
to talk about
the Russians as the font of all evil,
and he begins to emphasize
that something has to be done
to bring the Russians to their knees.
This resonates in all sorts of ways,
negative ways with the Russians.
So what I'm saying to you is,
from a Russian point of view,
it's the Europeans
who are the real devils in this story.
And it is the British and the Germans
among the European countries
who the Russians loathed the most.
Then we get to the Americans.
I think that there's no question that
the Russians understand
that the Americans started out to wreck
Russia as a great power to knock,
Russia off the list of great powers.
That was true in the Biden administration.
But I think that most Russians I talked
to do believe that President Trump
was interested
in trying to work out a deal
with the Russians to not only end the war
in Ukraine, but to improve relations
between Russia on one hand
and the United States on the other hand.
I think the Russians understood that.
Trump, to put it
in general terms, he had good intentions.
He was not Joe Biden.
But I think that the Russians
came to believe
that Trump was incapable
of reaching an agreement
that Trump and Steve Witkoff
and Jared
Kushner are basically incompetent.
There's no way
that they can settle this war.
And what happened at Anchorage
is just evidence of this.
So let me talk a little bit
about Anchorage.
And remember here,
what I'm trying to do is explain to you
why the Russians have come to think
that the Americans
are basically stumble bumps.
And here we're talking about
the Americans under President Trump.
The Anchorage meeting in August of 2025.
Remember, President Trump comes
into the white House in January 2025,
and he begins to go to work
to try and settle the war in Ukraine.
He had promised, as I'm sure everybody
remembers, that he was going to settle it
even before he got in the white House,
if he could.
And once he got back in the white House,
he would settle it very quickly.
So he went to work to do that.
President Trump shortly
after moving back into the white House.
And, over the course
of the summer of 2025,
he said, Steve Witkoff
to Moscow and Witkoff met with Putin.
And it turns out that they basically
worked out a compromise settlement.
And then President Trump
and President Putin met at Anchorage
in mid-August of 2025
for the purposes of shaking hands.
And agreeing
between themselves
that the deal that Wyckoff
and Putin had worked out
was satisfactory to both sides.
And it's important to emphasize
that this was a compromise deal.
The Russians actually made a number
of compromises
that I did not think they would make.
And at the time,
this is in mid-August 2025.
I didn't believe the stories
that Putin had agreed
to, the deal that had been worked out
between the two sides.
It just didn't make sense to me
that Putin would be willing
to make such compromises.
But it was quite clear from talking
to the Russians, and especially
from talking to Foreign Minister Lavrov,
that the Russians did compromise.
And basically with happened
here, is that
the Russians made some important
compromises regarding territory.
And let me explain what I mean by that.
There were four oblasts
that the Russians had annexed,
before President Trump
moved back into office in January 2025.
And two of those
oblasts are in the Donbas,
and the other two were Zaporizhzhia
and Kherson.
And the Russians had annexed the territory
and all four of those oblasts.
But the deal
that had been worked out in Anchorage
was that the Ukrainians
would withdraw from the territory
in the Donbas,
the two oblasts in the Donbas.
They would withdraw from that territory.
And, of course, the Russians
would take control of the entire Donbas.
But the Russians agreed that
the line of conflict
in Zaporizhzhia
and the line of conflict in Kherson
would remain in place, and in effect,
the Russians would not demand
that they get control
of all of Zaporizhzhia and all of Kherson,
even though they had formerly annexed
both of those oblasts.
So the Russians were making an important
compromise
on territory
regarding Zaporizhzhia and Kherson.
And this is what
I didn't think they would agree to.
But I was wrong.
The Russians made this deal with Trump,
and they had every reason to believe
that Trump was committed
to the deal, in large part
because it was proposed by Steve Wyckoff.
Just for important to understand that
this compromise was proposed by Witkoff
before the Anchorage
meeting agreed to by Witkoff and Trump
before Anchorage, and then agreed to at
Anchorage by Trump and Putin.
And what happened
was Trump was unable,
after the meeting in Anchorage,
to get the Ukrainians
and the Europeans to agree to the deal.
Trump had told Putin
that he could get the Ukrainians
and the Europeans on board.
Putin and Trump both understood,
of course, that the two of them
agreeing to a compromise deal
was a giant first step in terms
of getting a peace settlement.
But you had to get the Europeans and
you had to get the Ukrainians on board.
Trump was confident he could do that.
But what happened is, after Anchorage,
the Europeans and the Ukrainians
and the hardliners in the United States
all went to work on Trump.
And Trump backed off.
He walked away, in effect, from Anchorage.
And I would argue,
by the way, that it was
remarkably foolish of the Ukrainians
to walk away from this deal.
This was hardly
a perfect deal for the Ukrainians,
because they were going to end up
surrendering quite a bit of territory.
But I think from Ukraine's point of view,
it would have been much better
to accept that deal
than to accept the deal
that they're going to have to accept
when this war finally ends.
They're going to be much worse off
when this war finally ends than
they would have been had they accepted
the agreement worked out in Anchorage.
But be that as it may, the fact is,
that the the deal never materialized
because Trump could not get the Ukrainians
and the Europeans and the hardliners
in the United States to sign on
to the arrangement
that had been worked out in Anchorage.
The the end result of this
is that the Russians have lost all faith
in President Trump's ability to negotiate.
I mean, Putin may still meet
with Wyckoff and Kushner, but
he's just going through the motions.
The Russians understand full
well that the Americans are not capable
of delivering, and therefore this war
has to be settled militarily.
It has to be settled on the battlefield.
And with the air war.
This is the one two punch
that the Russians
are relying on to win this war.
Now,
let me close here by talking about what
I think the final deal will look like.
I've emphasized for a couple of years
now that the Russians would win
an ugly victory.
This has been my argument
all along, and I used this rhetoric
in my conversations
with a number of Russians.
I asked them,
point after point,
what the final deal would look like.
What do they think
the settlement is going to look like?
How do they think
this war is going to end?
I found that virtually nobody
would answer that question
in a concrete way.
No one would say
what the final arrangement will look like.
At some point
we're going to get a frozen conflict.
So what's the frozen conflict look like?
What are the territorial lines?
What are the specifics regarding
Ukraine being a neutral state
and so forth and so on.
And nobody could come up
with a concrete answer to that.
When it be clear the Russians do
believe they're going to win this war.
But exactly what winning means
is not clear.
Now, it's very important
that I emphasize that nobody in Russia
ever said to me that they envisioned
conquering all of Ukraine.
I find this hardly surprising.
The Russians would be foolish
in the extreme to try to conquer all
of Ukraine, because the ethnic Ukrainians
in the western half of that country
would make any occupation
of all of Ukraine a total nightmare.
So the Russians are not conquering
or bent on conquering all of Ukraine.
But they are going to take a large slice
of territory.
And my sense
talking to people, there were a few people
who said this out loud, but not many.
But my sense talking to people
is that they would prefer to conquer
more territory than just the four oblasts
that they've annexed,
which I was talking about before.
I think that there are a number
of Russians who would like to take Odessa,
and take Kharkiv
and a handful of other oblasts as well.
The Russians would like to push
as far west as possible,
in large part because they believe
that the remaining rump state
of Ukraine will be hostile to Russia.
So you see, what's happening here
is that the Russians understand
that the Ukrainians
are never going to be happy
with the status quo that is
set in place after the shooting stops.
The Ukrainians are going to want
their territory back.
They're going to want those oblasts
that they lost to Russia back,
and they're going to go to great
lengths to try to undermine
Russian control of the territory
that Russia takes away from Ukraine.
This incentivizes the Russians to take
as much territory as possible.
As much territory is
as is militarily feasible
to conquer
and politically feasible to occupy.
And again, where those lines are drawn
is hard to say at this point in time.
But again, the Russians are incentivized
to move as far west as possible,
and they're incentivized
to make sure that the rump Ukrainian state
that remains is as dysfunctional
as possible.
And again,
a number of Russians would say that
publicly or say that to me out loud.
But it was implicit in the comments of
a number
of other Russians that I talked to.
So I think that
there's no question that
the settlement that the Russians envision
imposing on Ukraine
will be a harsh settlement, for sure.
Now I want to make two final points.
One has to do with denazification.
The Russians talk
a lot about denazification in Ukraine,
and this means eliminating the hard line,
right wing, highly nationalistic,
Ukrainian elites
from positions of power
inside the Ukrainian government.
I personally do not see
how the Russians can do that.
As I've tried to make clear here,
we are going to end up with
a Ukrainian rub state and it's going to be
a dysfunctional rum state.
But I do not believe that the Russians
will be in a position
where they can determine
who runs that Rump state.
And I think once this war is over with,
the nationalists
will be a powerful political force
in Ukraine.
And maybe I should say
the ultra nationalist
will be a powerful political force
in Ukraine.
And those ultra nationalists
will fit the description
of the Russians as Nazis.
But I don't believe
the Russians will be able to.
And I'm using the Russian rhetoric.
Denazification, Ukraine.
I think the the hardline nationalists
will remain in power
in significant ways inside of Ukraine.
And my final point is that
in the West, it's widely believed
that not only are the Russians interested
and conquering all of Ukraine,
but they're a threat to Eastern Europe,
that the Russians
want to basically restore
the Soviet empire in Eastern Europe
if they can, and that they have.
A well-tuned army
at this point in time that they can use
for that purpose.
Now, this is to say that the West,
especially the Europeans, are facing
a significant threat from Russia.
I have never believed that.
And from talking to the Russians
on this visit,
I see no evidence, none,
that the Russians are interested
in conquering any territory in Europe.
As I said before, I saw no evidence,
not even a hint,
that the Russians were interested
in conquering all of Ukraine.
And as I said,
they would be foolish to try to do that,
and they would be foolish to try to
invade territory
in Eastern Europe or countries
in Eastern Europe,
which just happened to be members of NATO,
which causes all sorts of obvious problem.
So I think the only interesting question
on the table now
regarding where this war ends up
is, number one,
how much territory do
the Russians take in Ukraine?
In other words,
where do they stop moving west?
Number two, what is Ukraine's
relationship with the West moving forward?
Will Ukraine declare its neutrality,
or will it continue to posture
about joining NATO?
But regardless
of what happens on that front,
I think the Russians will be incentivized
to do everything they can to turn
Ukraine into a dysfunctional rump state
and keep it as a dysfunctional rump state.
All of this is to say that
this war has been one giant disaster.
And as I have said many times,
the decision in early April of 2008
to expand NATO into Ukraine,
to bring Ukraine into the alliance,
was one of the greatest strategic
blunders of modern times.
That concludes what I have to say
about my recent visit to Russia.
Thank you all for listening
and I look forward to our next episode.